i
[Música]
ah
mientras el salvador se prepara para
intensificar la reapertura económica el
próximo 24 de agosto los casos de kobe
19 muestran una baja tras haber
presentado alrededor de 500 casos
diarios en las últimas semanas las
autoridades reportan una disminución de
al menos 23 200 contagios por día al
punto que algunos hospitales no han
tenido ingreso de pacientes del gobierno
hasta por 24 horas en situación que no
se había presentado por varias semanas
aunque los contagios parecen ir a la
baja el presidente en la que le advirtió
que no se puede establecer como una
tendencia de comportamiento de la norma
ha dispuesto un plan que incluye la toma
de muestras masivas para detectar nuevos
contagios la entrega de medicamentos
para bajar la mortalidad y ayudar a
desconfiar y descongestionar los
hospitales a la vez que continúa con la
entrega de paquetes de alimentos a la
población también se fue se planea
emitir un carnet de inmunidad con
vigencia de ocho meses para personas
recuperadas de kobe 19 a la fecha la
pandemia suma más de 22 mil casos
positivos y cerca de 600 fallecidos en
el salvador
[Música]
guatemala es el país centroamericano con
la más alta tasa de letalidad por
muertes a raíz de la pandemia del cob y
19 de acuerdo a estadísticas
proporcionadas por la universidad de
hacking esta nación con casi 17 millones
de habitantes tiene el 3.8 por ciento de
letalidad lo que representa el 13.31 por
cada 100.000 habitantes hasta el momento
guatemala reportan más de 60.000
contagios y alrededor de 2 mil 296
muertes sin embargo en honduras la
pandemia sigue acelerándose a niveles
altísimos esta nación de 9 millones de
habitantes tiene el 31 por ciento de
letalidad el 16.08 por ciento por cada
100.000 habitantes de acuerdo a
estadísticas del sistema nacional de
riesgo honduras tiene casi 50 mil
contagios y más de 1500 muertes
[Música]
panamá es el país con el mayor número de
casos de kobe 19 en centroamérica de
hecho más del 30 por ciento de los
contagiados en esta parte del continente
corresponden a la nación canalera y esas
personas que han contraído el virus
representan cerca del 2 por ciento de su
población total dentro de este panorama
en américa central el mismo también
encabeza la tasa de muertes por cada
100.000 habitantes alrededor de 40 entre
las naciones latinoamericanas es
superado por perú chile brasil y méxico
ya han pasado cinco meses desde que se
conoció el primer caso en el país y en
buena parte de ese tiempo se ha
mantenido una cuarentena obligatoria de
género por día en los últimos días se
han hecho anuncios para la incorporación
de nuevas camas a la capacidad
hospitalaria
se han hecho convocatorias del personal
de salud a lo interno e incluso el
presidente de la república- laurentino
cortizo dijo que se estaba trabajando
para incorporar a médicos cubanos
a emergencia por la pandemia por otra
parte después de tres meses otro grupo
de sectores económicos que abrirán sus
puertas a partir de la próxima semana
entre ellos el comercio al detal